hi everyone hi how are you I'm good
Anna how are you good - when I studies
where doesn't that miss see so we're
gonna do our usual a little closer we're
gonna have our usual English in Spanish
mmm conversation yeah and you know what
I want to talk about today the other day
we had a discussion yes and I was saying
that everyone who starts at link should
be forced to do the many stories mm-hmm
because I like the mini stories I'm
finding them very useful I've used them
for Greek for Parsi for Arabic and you
said no because that's not what link is
link is the ability to access everything
all the content you love yeah continued
and that's very important
yeah and so that not only is there a lot
of different content in our library but
there's so much stuff on the Internet
yeah you know YouTube we mentioned how
you can import from YouTube I'm finding
even for Farsi you know the Persian
language yeah there's so much stuff that
I can import yeah so so that you're
better off to do so some people get
confused because there's too much
content or they don't know what to study
yeah
so that's also a problem yeah yeah yeah
one thing is that we have a lot of
content of the unbelievable library so
we can use that mm-hmm but all the thing
is that we can import everything we want
right for me I did the mini stories
having a beginning a lot it's very easy
mm-hmm but I think you say it's a like a
workout right that's like a workout yeah
it's like your refresh your mind about
the the basic of the languages but I
think if you have intermitted or I don't
know that in your English or another
language I think it's good for refresh
them right your mind and also for me
that I missed in marketing is your
marketing right I
helped a lot because every I don't know
if I can I want to learn about marketing
campaigns right I import this disposal
blog on only and read there because if I
don't know any war I can track I can see
so I think this is one of the most
important thing for me and I think
sometimes people don't understand the
this value I agree and and I was
thinking to you know I was looking at
home and some of the books that I bought
and I have lots of books for Corian for
Farsi for Arabic yeah and of course
whatever work you buy the amount of
content in the book is so limited yeah
so limited yeah and even if you do the
book you know and maybe you learn some
of the grammar and stuff but there are
you need so many words there's so much
content you need and the best source of
that is the internet so basically you
want to be able to access yeah bring it
in
yeah oh you were right yeah and I also
question yeah yeah this thing that
estimate every every video I say the
same but I know because I'm from Spain
and I'm everybody's I think the grammar
is so important but every day I study
with Lee I think the grammar is no
important not so good it is important it
is it's important to speak correctly but
you learn how to speak correctly if you
are exposed to a lot of content yeah
yeah and then when you're curious you
can look something up in it look I do I
look it up yes I look grammar also now
we have the telomerase or we can we can
search their ass but I think if you say
grammar or really reading and listening
I think is much more important there
than in grammar okay
that was big in Spanish because your
English has improved a lot see no better
Obama second thing weariness I know okay
ma'am well okay miss my only style pay
pay pay or on how many no no no yes
oh yes oh yeah over Farsi fighting or
see Athena spying on us
no
aprendiendo cuneus panama's pero
necesitamos creo que linkeyla limiters
por que para una persona que es medico
por que mucho contenido te pasa es tan
English market en la mayoría de las
disciplina zest an English por que es la
vamos habla de pues poder t import at OS
a continual ink track in de todo tu
proceso de el inlays poor creo que las
ventajas proportional engi creo que al
final essays okay a ver las puertas a a
quarter contend okay to Kiara's si yo
creo boys me experience here he has a
son Rahul - si si tu tienes una vida
comprehension wait when nivel de
competencia capillary Oh bye Santa
um Pio see too much a father applied
yeah
con difficult up up and hip yo pero la
tormenta SI tienes mucha spar lebra's
was hablar ya bloody n
entonces el italiano y y media s de
aprender palabra secrecies
eople they comprehend that yeah and you
know most importantly in this place see
it in this camera mucho para hablar yeah
yeah no tienes palabras ec2 montien
dislocated hello drop quite a
conversation sporty to know okay yeah
siempre con lo que me gusta la mayoría
passe work is when an English por
siempre Escala producción pasado caboose
Colby Oakley venue tally in Tolentino
una palabra at Roscoe esta es una manera
de aprender English yes I see yo creo
que Metheny some we important enough
brain okay see the gusta el contenido
CSM country on a Starfleet
with a surrender McCoy as you say in
English content we love right yeah so
anyway it sounded a bit of a like a bit
of a an ad for link but but it is again
Anna as a learner myself as a learner
learning different languages that this
has been our experience unfortunately a
lot of people are still looking for a
more traditional approach you know less
than one teach me the grammar study list
and and I think that's still a majority
people and so we have our little
campaign here to get people to switch to
more of a content-based infant based
approach which is what link offers yeah
didn't follow her into channel three
okay star once at the end or no promise
en Linea demo scare someone tiempo para
khatamun nabiyeen idioma porque no no
está de Manos proposed in Thursday ano
e para esta haciendo fuera del cuenta
por ciento de las cuentas anomalies si
que bueno si preston oade a
I think like a sheep and those two
Senegalese can you say the same thing in
English yeah yeah now it is time to
learn languages because it start a year
and people have resolutions so for hell
our community and we offer 40% off of
the annual membership okay on the shorts
the annual memberships yeah 40% off yeah
so I think they're very interesting yeah
and you know the good thing with that is
is is it's a commitment so if you're
just paying every month so you can quit
anytime yeah make that commitment for a
year and then give it a good year and
you're gonna see the result I think so
yeah okay yeah good all right thank you
see you okay
[Music]